- I think everyone's a liar.
And you're lying if you
say you're not a liar.
- I'm kind of worried that me being honest
is gonna make people
think that I'm inadequate,
or I'm a mean person.
- Maybe I lie to protect myself, but also,
I lie to protect other people.
- Sometimes the truth hurts,
and sometimes the truth is very dark,
and something that a lot
of people don't wanna hear.
- Being honest scares me, in
terms of all my relationships,
because I guess I lie to everybody.
- I swear to tell the truth.
- The whole truth.
- And nothing but the truth.
- For the next 24 hours.
(dramatic music)
- So the lady at the
Burger King drive through
gave me a compliment,
and she was like, "Oh I love your hair,
"oh I want your hair."
And I was like, you know what?
It's not mine, so you can have it too.
Just go to the store and buy it.
- I had a friend text me
asking if I wanted to hang out,
and I told them I had an audition,
caught myself, and had to write back,
no, I actually lied,
I just feel like lying in
my bed doing nothing today.
Felt very lame.
- Hey Steven.
- [Steven] Yeah?
- I never told you
this, but before we met,
I liked your dog a lot more than you.
- What?
- I'm sorry.
I'm just being honest.
- So I went to dinner,
and the waiter asked us how our meal was.
- And what did you tell her?
- It wasn't good.
- You can't say that to
waiter, you can't do that.
- But it was cold, it wasn't very good.
- So I just got back from this date.
A few things.
He appreciated that I was
honest about a lot of things.
I think that, you know,
it allowed him to open up
and be a lot more honest about himself,
because I was being so blunt.
And I was like, "Hey, we
vibe really well as friends.
"Maybe we should hang out
next time as friends."
I didn't even know how to say that.
It was.
So, honesty kind of sucked today.
- Being honest for a day
made me feel like an asshole.
- I was honest for a day, and in the end,
nothing really changed.
Like, the world didn't blow up,
I still have my friends,
I still have my family.
I went on a date and I
didn't like the person,
and now I never have to
see them again, it's great.
- Being honest didn't ruin my life.
Nothing changed.
I still have my mom, and
she didn't disown me.
My boyfriend still lives with me
and he hasn't disowned me yet,
and I still have my job so
things are going smoothly.
- I think that was just a relief,
just to kinda let go
of that side of myself
that wants to be a people pleaser
and wants to put my best face forward
instead of really saying
what's on my mind.
- Maybe I should start
being a little more honest
about the small stuff,
and see what happens,
and push myself out of my comfort zone.
- I'm really glad that
we did this experiment,
just because it's kind of put
things in perspective for me.
It's a little bit more important for me
to feel comfortable, and
for me to feel happy,
than to compromise all of that
for the happiness of others.
(ambient soft rock music)